[Musique]
annick girardin ministre d outre mer
s'est rendu au salon international de
l'agriculture ce lundi 24 février
la ministre a ainsi pu visiter chaque
stand du village réunion qui s'étend sur
600 m² ce village de 2020 il est va
encore plus loin que celui de l'an
dernier avec des nouveaux exposants des
nouveaux produits une diversification
toujours une montée en gamme des
produits de la réunion
vous savez je l' ai déjà dit sur place
dans l'île de la réunion combien
l'organisation de vos filières avait été
largement accompagné soutenu on y trouve
de la qualité de l'excellence la
recherche de produits nouveaux
l'innovation est au coeur de
l'agriculture ou du développement de
l'agriculture à la réunion moi je veux à
nouveau félicité bien sûr l'ensemble des
exposants qui sont là qui travaillent au
quotidien et qui font en lames de de la
réunion mais aussi le département qui
accompagnent ces agriculteurs
un peu plus tard la réunion a pu faire
découvrir ses produits aux premiers
ministres edouard philippe un
accord-cadre de 4 ans a été signé entre
le ministère des outre-mer la cirad
l'inra et l'ird et cet accord vise à
déployer en outre-mer l'initiative
internationale 4 pour moon les sols pour
la sécurité alimentaire et le climat
[Musique]